well I think what is good about what
you're saying is you're talking about
seizing the opportunity and you're
talking about using whatever whatever
prospects come along to get where you
want to get to I think there's a there's
almost like a Schism in this
conversation isn't there because I think
what what these guys are talking about
and and probably what I'm talking about
is more mindset based and over here
we're getting into the Weeds about some
of these social issues which do exist
100 they do exist But ultimately overall
what we need to do we need to transcend
that because actually I mean social
class is a huge thing as well right and
actually you've sort of paid lip service
to that I mean it's not like Richie
sunac he's the prime minister of the
United Kingdom but he came from an
incredibly privileged background right
so social class is a big thing whether
you're black or white or Asian or
whatever
um but people from very um
underprivileged social backgrounds can
also go on to become hugely successful